Alors, ça a pris 10 kilos ?!
Hein ? Le foie gras, le saumon fumé, tout ça...
Les amis , aujourd'hui je fais cette petite vidéo
pour faire un petit point sur 2016
et vous parler de plusieurs choses.
2016 pour moi ça a été une année assez ouf,
assez bien remplie en vidéos, on a fait plein plein de conneries cette année
et je pense vraiment que c'est l'année
où on a sorti le plus de vidéos cools
en tout cas qui me plaisent à moi et dont je suis fier.
Parce que ouais y a forcément des vidéos qui sont bien
mais tu les mets en ligne tu fais bon ouais pas incroyable
et d'autres où t'es vraiment content et là cette année j'ai vraiment
fait une majorité de vidéos où je suis très content
du résultat et tout ça c'est grâce au fait
que maintenant je ne bosse plus tout seul je suis avec
Clément que vous connaissez déjà et qui notamment qui
me cadre les vidéo HTC vive etc... Ça me
permet de pas être seul dans mon coin, de pas m'isoler
du monde et de vivre les choses et
d'apprécier encore plus mon
métier aujourd'hui qui est d'être youtuber, c'est un métier, c'est un métier !
A cela s'ajoute le fait que maintenant j'ai
ce nouveau studio qui n'est pas chez moi et p****n
ça fait du bien y a pas mal de
personnes d'entre vous qui ne comprenez pas pourquoi
c'était bien d'avoir un studio et ils voyaient ça plutôt comme "Ah
ouais c'est nul tu te professionnalises, c'est de la m****,
c'était mieux dans ta chambre, t'as changé." Non pas du tout au
contraire, en fait maintenant vu que je ne suis plus chez moi
je suis plus entre les mêmes quatre murs
de dix heures jusqu'à minuit, parce que ouais
(je suis) j'étais dans mon bureau
quand je jouais pour le plaisir et aussi quand je faisais des vidéos
et aussi quand je faisais le montage et aussi
quand je buvais un café, c'était horrible ! Et bah là je vais au travail
comme tout le monde, le matin je pars de chez moi comme ça je suis dans
les bouchons je rage. Et j'vais dans ce p****n
de bureau dans lequel j'me sens encore mieux que
dans mon ancien bureau parce que c'est pas chez moi et quand j'vais
ici je sais pourquoi je suis là et je sais ce que je vais faire.
Ça m'a fait énormément de bien et ça,
même au niveau des vidéos j'pense qu'on peut voir que je
prends un mais un plaisir infini par
rapport à avant où je commençais un peu à être fumé comme le saumon que t'as
mangé il y a quelques jours. Ça m'a permis de me
ressourcer et de reprendre un max de plaisir dans ce que je faisais donc
ça c'est vraiment parfait et aussi
avez vous remarqué que les vidéos sont un peu plus matures ?
Non ? Ça fait bientôt six ans qu'on est sur youtube
les amis vous vous rendez compte, six ans. À l'époque on était
très très jeune, on avait pas de barbe on avait la voix
qui muait à mort... Bon moi elle mue encore un peu mais c'est pas voulu,
et en fait on a muri, on a grandi et
je vois de plus en plus de personnes qui retombent sur les vidéos
qu'ils n'avaient pas regardé depuis trois, quatre ans et qui maintenant
apprécient et y a même une sorte de truc qui
consiste à avoir un peu honte de dire qu'on apprécie les
vidéos de Squeezie en 2016. Mais
ça change, le contenu évolue et nous avec
et du coup ouais ça m'étonne pas en fait c'est
plus mur c'est moins "ouahhhhhhh" on fait des
vidéos un peu plus posées je trouve, parfois
même un peu plus réfléchies avec un but psychologique comme sur
pas mal de jeu qu'on a fait cette année et ça avait l'air de
vous plaire à fond donc je suis hyper content. J'ai reçu plein de messages
de gens qui me disaient qu'avant ils détestaient les vidéos et maintenant
ils aiment bien, ils trouvent ça un peu plus posé, un peu plus mature et
c'est bon je veux quand même pas qu'on fasse des vidéos sérieuses
à fond hein mais en tout cas dans notre connerie
on est plus mature qu'avant ça c'est sûr. Voilà
je suis vraiment moi même, j'aime ce que je fais c'est pour ça que des fois
je suis un petit peu plus posé dans des vidéos que dans d'autres, des
fois je suis un peu plus foufou et je crois que le contenu que je fais m'a
jamais autant correspondu. Je vais pas
vous mentir cette fin d'année elle était très très chargée
à cause de The Last Guardian, fin "à cause" c'était
pas vraiment un truc que j'ai subi... au contraire
j'ai hyper apprécié, mais c'était des vidéos
ça faisait du montage à faire en plus et du temps
à passer en plus à tourner. Alors c'était très kiffant
mais le seul souci c'est que ça s'ajoute
aux vidéos que je faisais déjà de base
donc les quatre vidéos normales par semaines je devais en faire
trois ou quatre de plus et c'étaient celles de
"The Last Guardian". Donc ça faisait une quantité de taff
assez énorme et j'avais peur d'être
un peu démotivé par le fait
de doubler ma charge de travail mais
que les gens ne suivent pas le truc. Je veux dire
"The Last Guardian" je m'attendais pas à ce que ça marche aussi bien
ça a cartonné (vieille expression) sur la chaîne youtube
je suis encore étonné qu'il y ait autant de gens qui
aient apprécié l'aventure qui aient suivi parce que
c'est lent, des fois on tourne un peu en rond dans le jeu
(je retire les) je cut au montage les passages où je
tourne en rond mais bon voilà c'est quand même très posé très lent
c'est une ambiance particulière et qui,
qui n'a rien à voir avec ce qu'on fait habituellement et p****n
en grande partie vous avez adoré
tous les épisodes ont fait au moins un million de vues
et j'étais vraiment surpris et du coup je me suis
dit p****n ça, ça, ça a valu
le coup de doubler ma charge de travail parce que les gens
suivent ce truc. Donc merci pour ça, je
sais que Trico vous manque aujourd'hui, que vous aimeriez que
Sony sorte "The Last Guardian" 2 demain et bah moi aussi.
S'ils peuvent même le sortir cet après-midi ça me va.
En fait je trouve que c'était le meilleur truc qu'on pouvait faire
pour bien conclure l'année, à savoir faire un peu plus de
vidéos mais dans un délire complètement
différent quitte à ce que ça marche moins bien et au final
ça n'a pas moins bien marché que le reste parce que vous
avez complètement adhéré et p****n ... merci.
Mais du coup vu que cette fin d'année était
très très très chargée, je me prends des
petites vacances !  Oui oui oui le R.T.T
toi même tu sais. Les amis demain
je pars en Corée...
du Sud. Ouah!!! J'y étais déjà allé en
mars pendant cinq jours avant d'enchaîner sur le Japon
où je vous avait fait pas mal de vlogs en fait j'ai,
j'ai pas fait énormément de choses là-bas
et c'est mon plus grand regret. J'me dis p****n mais je suis allé cinq
jours en Corée et quand on me dit qu'est-ce que t'as fait là-bas...
...euh des, des boutiques.
Je suis un bolosse. Et j'aimerais vraiment
ne plus jamais avoir cette réponse ah ah
donc j'ai décidé d'y retourner une semaine
(une petite 'fin) huit jours pour être exact.
Je pars demain en début d'après-midi alors je vous ai fait des
petites vidéos d'avance mais pas trop en fait
je pars demain et je reviens du coup le cinq
novembre... janvier ? Novembre ! Je reviens le
cinq janvier donc le jeudi d'après et y aura des vidéos
du coup cette semaine, là, pas de soucis mais la semaine
prochaine donc la première semaine de janvier y en aura,
y aura sûrement un ou deux vlog de Corée (parce que c'est,)
j'ai trop envie de vous faire découvrir des trucs, j'ai un programme vraiment
trop cool là-bas, je me suis fait un petit programme
ça va être complètement barré, vous allez adorer. Et j'ai
vraiment envie de vous montrer un peu ce que je vais faire là-bas mais du coup
pour la première semaine de janvier voilà j'ai
rien prévu niveau vidéos d'avance parce que
déjà en faire trois d'avance ça m'a demandé
pas mal de taff et si j'en faisais plus
les vidéos allaient être un peu pourries. C'est des vidéos dont je vais être
un peu moins fier parce que je me suis pressé un peu pour les faire,
j'ai dû trouver les idées comme ça rapidement et
je sais que je vais pas être content de mettre ça en ligne ça va me
faire chier donc je préfère ne rien mettre en ligne et juste vous
proposer les vlog de Corée, qui je suis sûr, vont
vous plaire. Je reviendrais donc le cinq janvier donc le jeudi
et le six et sept janvier j'ai un
tournage pour une vidéo qui arrivera
à la fin du mois de janvier sur ma chaîne.
Du coup le retour de Corée va être un peu violent parce que ça va être un tournage
de p****n sur 48 heures on va bosser
38 c'est sûr ! Mais p****n ça va valoir le coup
en plus y'a plein de potos youtuber qui sont
dans le projet et... Ah j'ai hâte de vous montrer !
Enfin bon tout ça pour dire que 2016 pour moi
sur youtube, ça a été je pense, de ces cinq dernières années
passées à faire des vidéos, ça a été la meilleure
dans le sens où j'ai proposé des vidéos dont je suis le
plus fier j'ai fait les vidéos
que je voulais faire je ne me suis pas forcé à faire
tel ou tel truc, j'ai été le plus moi même je trouve
et en plus j'ai eu ce (donc ce)
nouveau studio c'était une nouvelle manière de bosser
avec Clément et ça m'a fait un bien
fou, c'était le vent frais qu'il
me fallait et je pense que vous
l'avez remarqué dans les vidéos globalement, parce que
comme j'ai dit même des gens qui ne regardaient plus du tout les vidéos
et qui sont retombés dessus récemment ils se disent p*****
mais c'est bien en fait maintenant et, et ça pour moi
juste cette phrase c'est, ce comportement là
de gens qui reviennent des années après et qui apprécient
c'est une victoire je me dis p****n c'est cool
ça prouve que j'évolue que je grandis que je mûris
que je propose des trucs différents qui plaisent et
qui plaisent plus parfois aux gens parce que, ça peut ne
plus plaire aussi. Mais que ça plaise ou non ça marque l'évolution
et je trouve que c'est important d'évoluer dans ce que
je fais et pas de trop stagner et de rester sur ses acquis
voilà. Euh, la millième vidéo
par exemple, on n'est pas resté sur nos acquis hein,
ah ah ! Bref, merci pour tout, j'espère que 2017
sera encore meilleur je sais pas comment on va pouvoir faire encore meilleur
parce que j'ai jamais été autant épanoui.
on trouvera un moyen vous en faites pas !
Au pire, un petit saumon fumé, moi ça me met bien ça m’épanouit
Du coup je vous souhaite quoi là (?) je vous souhaite une bonne
seconde semaine de vacances, un bon nouvel an, hein.
profitez bien de vos cadeaux, de votre famille,
de votre nouveau pc gamer peut être pour certains ou
de votre console. Merci pour tout, merci pour cette année moi
je m'en vais en Corée finir en beauté l'année
puis je reviendrai bien en forme et pour vous proposer
des trucs encore meilleurs j'espère. J'espère que les vidéos que
j'ai fait en avance pour cette semaine vous plairont et puis on se retrouve
la semaine prochaine pour du vlog en Corée.
Portez-vous bien, ciao tout le monde, bonne fin d'année
PEACE !